[Music]
we're eternals
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
[Music]
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
welcome back everyone this will be my
new eternals trailer video they just
released a new imax trailer that's a
little bit different than the last one
so there's a bunch of easter eggs and i
figured it's a good opportunity to talk
about the new marvel cosmic hierarchy
and explain the celestials and where
everybody fits in now because as you've
seen from the spider-man no way home
trailer it is getting so crazy in marvel
phase four so if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos the eternals movie is coming
up next month so we're gonna start
seeing a whole bunch more footage for it
really soon too and i will explain where
kang in the multiverse war figures into
all this like he who remains because
obviously on the loki series we saw that
he'd been controlling the main mcu
timeline the sacred timeline from start
to finish the whole time so he would
have been watching over the birth of
eternity the celestials the eternals
everything that played out from the
start of the timeline to the very end of
time but there is still a hierarchy of
cosmic beings in the mcu that are way
more powerful than anything we've seen
before so the eternals movie is really
just the introduction to some of those
cosmic beings is not meant to be a one
and done with the celestial host they're
way too powerful for that but the
movie's also meant to tell the true
origin of the celestials in the actual
origin of the universe the marvel
cinematic universe in a more traditional
way than the sacred timeline the kang
gave us which represents the main mcu
universe we've been operating in
throughout all the marvel movies so far
so when he who remains kang was telling
us his backstory he was kind of giving
us a backstory on the universe and
during the guardians of the galaxy movie
the collector kind of gave us a
backstory on the universe but it's
really only part of the story the
eternals movie is going to fill in all
those gaps what he who remains king on
loki started to explain though was the
cycle of big bangs like this is not the
first version of the universe that
you're living in it's a loop it operates
on a loop universe is born in the big
bang eventually dies heat death then is
reborn in a new version of the universe
so in the mcu we don't know which
version of the universe we're in we just
know that it's been through a couple of
cycles already but before the big bang
there was something it was basically
called utter chaos the void where the
dark elves were born where beings like
schumachorth ruled over chaos lords but
when the first big bang happens and the
first universe is born it has a
consciousness it's called eternity so
the universe itself is alive
[Music]
eventually that universe winds up dying
its heat death then contracts again goes
through another big bang cycle becoming
the second version of the universe the
only thing that he who remains kang did
to mess with this process the cycle of
big bangs the birth and rebirth of the
universe is that he only changes things
so that everything will play out the
same or close to the same in every
single time loop start to finish where
you get to the multiverse of it all is
that during the second big bang that's
when the multiverse was born there's
still just one version of eternity one
consciousness for it all though also
during the second big bang is when the
infinity stones are created when the
collector was explaining them to the
guardians of the galaxy he said before
the big bang there were six
singularities that survived the big bang
process and then were forged into ingots
actual infinity stones that story is
only half the story the six
singularities were the remnants of the
former version of the universe they
represent all the cosmic power of that
entire universe distilled down into six
singularities so when you're wielding
the infinity stones you're wielding the
cosmic power of an entire universe
that's why you're able to affect things
on a universe-wide scale when i say
galactus was also created the same way
the infinity stones were created he
started out as a scientist named galen
who just survived the heat death of his
own universe in the next big bang and
during that big bang process he was
imbued with immense cosmic energy
changing him into galactus galactus is
similar to the celestials in some ways
but the reason eternity created him was
to destroy dying worlds so that new life
could grow inside the cosmos like when
farmers do controlled burns on their
fields to help enrich the soil but on a
cosmic scale so just like the celestials
galactus isn't really good or evil only
the worlds he consumes think of him as a
villain but he serves a very important
cosmic purpose but also starting in this
second big bang and then future big
bangs that would eventually happen in
each of the different universes eternity
winds up creating the first celestial
host the ones that we see walking around
in all the marvel trailers in the mcu
they're led by airshim the judge this
giant red celestial who they're calling
the prime celestial all the celestials
have kind of funny names that describe
what they do the first celestial host
was irishman the judge obviously it's in
the name he judges things jamiah the
calculator who's also nowhere the head
of the dead celestial on present day
i'll explain that in a second too
because you can kill celestials but it's
really really hard there's nazar the
calculator hargan the measurer issan the
searcher who we also saw during the
guardians of the galaxy movie and then
also ego the living planet because he
was a celestial inside the mcu but he's
kind of like a rogue celestial so even
though eternity gives birth to these new
celestials and tells them to go out and
garden experiment with life in the
universe if you're a fan of the berserk
manga they're kind of like the god hand
they're not good they're not evil just
go out and do as thou would wilts try
experimenting with things ego the living
planet is different because he's a rogue
celestial so even though it might seem
like eternity is telling the celestials
what to do it's actually not quite like
that it just creates them and then just
lets them go out and do whatever it is
that they feel like doing imagine the
world's worst absentee parent so ego the
living planet doesn't feel like being
part of the celestial host they don't
force him to be part of the celestial
host but when eternity creates the
celestials it imbues them with immense
cosmic power and just to give you an
idea for how much cosmic power they
wield you could probably slow one down
temporarily just for like a hot second
with one infinity stone but you need the
entire infinity gauntlet to actually
have a chance at stopping one they use
vibranium to form a lot of their actual
bodies like the physical bodies that
they walk around in so a lot of people
theorize that the vibranium mound in
wakanda was actually sent to planet
earth or they orchestrated things that
celestials did so that that vibranium
would be used in the creation of the
brand new celestial that's growing in
planet earth the best sense for scale
that i could give you would be some of
these comic book panels here with them
just towering over everything so really
only beings like galactus have a chance
of actually fighting celestials without
a huge power up if you're a big comic
book fan iron man actually wore the god
killer armor that was actually an iron
man suit that was essentially a
celestial iron man suit created by some
dark versions of the celestials called
the aspirants they're not going to be
doing that in the movies anytime soon
but it was a really cool comic book
twist the size of the celestial host
fluctuates over time like i said you can
kill celestials like you did see nowhere
the head of a dead celestial during
guardians of the galaxy in present day
and they can actually reproduce so to
speak kind of they can create more
celestials but it takes millions and
millions of years in massive amounts of
cosmic energy that you just don't find
in present day so that's why you don't
see thousands of celestials flying
around in space but because there are
millions of worlds in the universe for
them to experiment on and there's only a
couple celestials they create lesser
beings to basically delegate a lot of
the management too in the mcu that
actually starts with the deviance that
you see like crow here he's one of the
antagonists of the film you see him with
angelina jolie's thena character so the
celestial host sends this celestial egg
to planet earth to slowly hatch it over
millions of years but it's meant to
slowly absorb enough cosmic energy in
order to mature and in order for that to
happen there needs to be life on planet
earth and at some point in history the
deviants start going around going rogue
ignoring the celestial's orders killing
off humans everywhere hurting the
chances that this new celestial will be
born so then the celestials create the
eternals to go kill the deviants then
take their place shepherding the
maturation process of this celestial egg
so there's this clever trick that they
pull with the trailer footage they make
it seem like the eternals believe that
they were sent to planet earth to
shepherd over humanity and watch them
grow like they fall in love with
humanity just in general when really the
celestials don't care about humans at
all they're just a food source like a
cosmic food source for this new
celestial that they're trying to grow so
there's a big change in the way the
eternals are created in the mcu than the
comics in the mcu they basically create
them with celestial technology to look
humanoid but they're kind of like living
celestial robots which is part of the
reason why they're immortal eternal
functionally they're like better
celestial versions of vision so they're
also kind of soft programmed like wet
wear programmed to obey the celestial's
commands which is why cersei is
explaining to dane whitman's black
knight character kit harrington's
character why they didn't help out fight
thanos during avengers infinity war
avengers end game the main reason is
they were kind of programmed to not pay
attention to things unless the deviants
were threatening the celestial's true
goal of incubating this brand new
celestial that's the emergence that
they're talking about like i said the
celestials can create new celestials and
that's what they're secretly using earth
for i think the trailer does a pretty
decent job of giving you an idea for the
power scaling of the eternals in the mcu
they're about as powerful as someone
like the hulk or thor or even captain
marvel that's about as powerful as they
are in the comics like they're not crazy
god level powerful like they couldn't
attack a celestial by themselves and
they're kind of programmed to not be
able to attack the celestials but for
those of you wondering like if icarus
fought thor who would win in that fight
it'd be pretty even match most of the
eternals names are actually named after
mythical or biblical figures because all
these religious stories that you read
about these great deeds that people
performed in ancient history they're
secretly talking about things that the
eternals walked around doing using their
powers so really the actual main
villains of the film are the celestials
themselves even though they themselves
aren't really good or evil in the cosmic
sense of things but just in terms of
power levels he who remains king could
have used his quantum energy in control
of time to fight the celestials if he
wanted to but part of the idea of the
eternals movie is that a lot of these
characters will come back in future
films and obviously there'll be sequels
to the eternals movie as well like
eternals 2 eternals 3 where they'll get
into more of the backstory of the mcu
and hopefully see the birth of thanos it
would be cool to see him being born in
one of the sequels because he is an
eternal just like them it's just the
group of eternals that he comes from
came from the planet titan but if you
have any big questions about the
celestials or how the origin of the mcu
works or these cosmic beings like
eternity just write them below in the
comments and i'll add them in my future
videos my full marvel what if episode 8
video will post wednesday just like
normal they're having their own version
of a giant multiverse crossover everyone
click here for my eternals video about
kit harrington's black knight character
and click here to learn all about that
brand new spider-man no way home lawsuit
that's happening thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and i'll see
you in the next video
[Music]